out our city is all about the vegas
golden knights both on and off the ice
two of the team's prominent players are
using their celebrity status to raise
some awareness now that's because they
recently adopted dogs from an
organization that saves animals from
slaughter overseas and then gives them
loving homes across the country
including las vegas sasha loftis has the
story
[Music]
he's known for his star power on the
[Music]
ice theodore defenseman and original
member of the golden knights
[Music]
hey we know he inspires las vegas but
what many have yet to learn about is his
love for these two wagging tails you
know i come in the room and they're both
kind of pretty excited and you know
they'll jump around meet bruce and max a
dog he and his fiance mariana alston
recently adopted seems like when one guy
gets one you know the next guy is like
hey like it's been awesome for us white
cloud a wrist shot and he scored and
shay isn't the only familiar face with a
rescue pup
fellow golden knight zach white cloud
and his girlfriend madison wetterspoon
recently welcomed wally into their home
we love all the goldens and they're
probably a team favorite and these team
favorites didn't come from a local
shelter but instead
traveled more than 6 000 miles you're
saving you know a dog from a situation
where you know it's not not ideal and
you know a lot of them you know need
savings
and they got here with help from
danielle roth and john lapolla of
retriever rescue of las vegas there's
nothing like it in the world the love
that they'll give you back
since 2019 these two have made it their
mission to rescue dogs like max and
wally from devastating lives in south
korea certain countries especially korea
which is our
target we have a chance of ending what
is known as dog meat farms and dog meat
slaughter houses there you go so far
they've found
528 of them loving homes
but their work is ever changing
as they try to end animal cruelty
overseas
with help from prominent families like
these
they really wanted to help and they
really wanted to make a difference you
know most of them aren't from las vegas
but they've accepted our city in
such amazing ways that's so fun
danielle says this kind of celebrity
support has really put their cause on
the map
and they can't begin to describe how
much that means it's amazing because
children reach out
that's their star or
theodore's their star me and paul
give me a paw
the golden knights have proven their
power to lift our city
now they're using their potential to
change the world just knowing
the difference that like even we made
just in max's life these dogs may not be
vegas born
but the life they scored means they will
always win when you give a dog i feel
like you know a loving home and food and
you know everything you know they need
it's
you know it's it's very rewarding
sasha loftis live local now